there's a funny thing that's sort of
quietly happening which is that more and
more Republicans are just quitting
politics in order to at least in part
get away from a Republican Party that's
led by Donald Trump and which might
actually reelect Donald Trump to a
second term the latest is Texas
Congressman Mike Conaway he's announced
that he's just not going to try to get
reelected in 2020 he's going bye-bye and
officially he hasn't said yet that this
is about Trump necessarily but we have
other Republicans on record saying that
serving under Donald Trump is an
embarrassment we've got former
Republican congressman Tom Davis who
told the hill quote serving in the era
of Trump has few rewards he has made an
already hostile political environment
worse every day there is some
indefensible tweet or comment to defend
or explain it is exhausting and often
embarrassing we already heard from Paul
Mitchell Pete Olson Martha Roby Rob
Bishop Republican members of Congress
that they're just bailing they're going
away they're quitting you'll remember on
the set aside back in 2018 that
Republican Senator Jeff Flake said he
was bailing out after very public spots
with Donald Trump may have even been
2017 hard to keep track of how quickly
things are happening that seat was
ultimately lost by Republicans and was
won by Democratic senator now Democratic
senator Kyrsten Sinema
so there are probably some additional
opportunities for Democrats as a result
of this you you've got of the five
Republican members of Congress that are
retiring four are in pretty safe
Republican districts Pete Olsen's
district is maybe winnable and there's
also the possibility that these
Republican members of Congress just kind
of realized that Democrats are probably
keeping control of the house in 2020
maybe even extending their control
they're not thrilled with the idea of
another two years out of power
particularly under Donald Trump and so
in total it's not because of Trump alone
they're just going to bail and there's
something funny about this which is that
we've heard rumblings for month about
this about Republicans who don't want to
be serving under Donald Trump but if
there were enough of them with a spine
instead of
quitting they could get together and
actually push back against Donald Trump
sort of acting like the
check-and-balance
to the white house that they're supposed
to be instead of merely being
subservient and I know that in a sort of
strict constitutional sense there is
some degree of subservience but I'm
using the term a little bit more
colloquially I got emails from some
people in our audience saying I actually
respect these politicians who are
leaving because they don't want to serve
under Donald Trump that's fine I'd
respect them more if they stayed and
actually stood up to Trump and changed
this path that the Republican Party has
taken in the era of Trump ISM ultimately
whatever the reason is that they're
leaving it's good in the sense that it's
an opportunity for a seat to be turned
Democratic even if many of these are
safe Republican seats it's still sort of
early but soon we're going to start
looking at House and Senate 2020 the
broad stroke as Democrats are likely to
keep the house the question is do they
extend their majority or not Democrats
are almost 100% not going to take the
Senate and I know every time I mentioned
this I get emails from people who don't
seem to get it it's not my opinion of
the tone or direction of the country
it's only one third of senators are up
for re-election each cycle the seats
that are up for re-election this cycle
favor Republicans keeping control of the
Senate I just don't see any path to
Democrats taking over the Senate in 2020
the idea would be try to retain the Doug
Jones seat don't lose more than one or
two seats net and then maybe be in a
position in 2022
hopefully with a Democratic president in
the White House at that point to take
over control of the Senate in the
midterm that will come in three years I
guess it is at this point in time if you
believe Democrats can take the Senate in
2020 get in touch and tell me how
because I simply don't see it if you
love learning new things you probably
want to check this out the David Pakman
show today is sponsored by Skillshare
and we're giving you two entire months
of free access to Skillshare when you
click the link underneath this video
Skillshare is a vibrant online
learning community offering more than
25,000 video classes on just about
anything you can think of get better at
playing an instrument learn to use
Photoshop how to edit videos they have
classes on drawing painting business
cooking nutrition personal productivity
and I'm not even really scratching the
surface I recently took a great class on
introductory watercolour painting I'm
still not good but I am learning and you
can access the entire library of fun
easy-to-use online courses for free for
two months by using the link underneath
this video two months of learning
something that's totally new to you
something you want to get better at
something you already love or you can
get ahead in your career by learning new
skills that will help you at your job
I've gotten a ton out of it Pat has
taken some courses that he's found
really valuable and I think you'll love
it to get started for free by clicking
the link under this video